hasn't Maui suffered enough
nope Joe arrives and it's rough
the president and first lady visited
Hawaii yesterday to witness firsthand
the destruction and tragedy in the wake
of the historic Wildfire Joe hasn't seen
destruction like that since he passed
the inflation reduction Act
political humor
he was also forced to leave his luxury
Lake Tahoe vacation as a result he had
to cancel three bicycle crashes
and and four ponytail sniffings
yeah
[Applause]
the little girls go around this little
thing
it's called anyway Joe tried to offer
sympathy with an off-told story about a
small kitchen fire he experienced in
2004 but it provided comic relief
instead I wonder what happened 15 years
ago when he was in Washington doing Meet
the Press on a Sunday Sunday
15 years ago I was in Washington doing
Meet the Press
it was a sunny Sunday
enlightening struck at home
on a little Lake that's outside of our
home not on like a big pond and hit the
wire and came up underneath our home
into the heating ducts the air
conditioning duct make a long story
short almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette
and my cat ah
just think if Joe had lost his Corvette
he wouldn't have any place to store all
those classified dogs but
but that's
here's what's really disgusting his
famous kitchen fire story we've heard
over and over again
it's been called to question more than
once that kitchen Inferno has been
called into question more often than
Jill Biden's doctor degree
that Blaze was doused in 20 minutes
despite Biden's saying in the past that
they almost lost a couple of
firefighters and had a house burned down
with his wife in it didn't happen like
that and watch what happened at the end
of Biden's presser when someone offered
him some water
interesting
I mean clearly this guy is somewhere
else other than Earth
but I said it before this is the
quietest tragedy ever as Glenn Greenwald
accurately noted Bush was mauled for
merely flying over New Orleans during
Katrina and Ted Cruz was mocked for
fleeing Texas during an electricity
crisis but the media won't dare give
equal treatment to Biden what's Joe got
to say
look I've suffered man uh I can relate
not only did I get struck by lightning
but uh one time at the Delaware Beach
house after Hunter was there for the
weekend we had a bit of a plumbing back
up in one of the bathrooms and uh
I mean that toilet exploded it was like
it could only be compared to the mighty
monologue volcano
and ever since then I've had a great
connection to the Hawaiian people
you'd have the bottom bottom line here
if he can't even pull off something this
straight forward you know visit and
offer Comfort to people who are grieving
that how can we really believe that he's
in charge of this country I don't want
to say Joe's totally out of it but the
next Island he wants to visit is the one
where seven Castaways set sail on a
three-hour Tour on a boat called The
Minnow
[Applause]
are being aloof he's not there and
shouldn't there be somebody who's in
charge of preserving the Dignity of this
guy instead of sending him places where
it's embarrassing oh man uh well there's
a couple of things that's wrong here
first of all the fact that they're
allowed and bond to move out all around
like this and we haven't seen Kamala at
all yeah shows you that the Illuminati
sat at the table was like we can't let
oh
yeah
I'm not even sure I know what the
Illuminati is
should I know who they are I don't know
oh you do
I could be a member of them if I if I
only filled out that form
but then but then they offer them a cut
right and they're wondering why they
offer them a cup why didn't he drink
from the cup well it's because if they
would have put a sign on it I said
whites only
hit a drink that
[Applause]
makes makes bushes Katrina situation
look like MLK or Selma yeah
just a poor mishandling
bad all right Tyrus where'd he go I just
stop don't even ask me a damn question
all right look
we in so much trouble
it's not even funny could you if I was a
dictator in any country I'd be like get
a meeting with him now by the time it's
over we'll have Nebraska the Midwest
will be ours but he's so lost he didn't
know where he was yeah and the only
thing he but he corrects himself on the
dumbest it was a lake no it was a pond
oh yeah
now you've got my attention
no no I remember it was a heating duck
but the the truly sadness of this whole
thing is that
the President coming is supposed to be
the sign that good times are on the way
the president's here he's going to take
care of things it's going to be better
and I just want to remember a time the
last time a president showed up do we
have the footage of the last time a
president showed up can we run it please
I just want us all to remember this
remember that oh yeah look at that
President Trump there actively they're
in a flood and what is he doing throwing
them paper towels super absorbent paper
towels they had a need and he was there
he was positive he's here I'm help he's
throwing towels he's sending money he's
being presidential and they still had a
problem with that yeah but I will take
throwing towels instead of just someone
ask you for a glass of water and you
think it's a race you just take off
cat why do you think he keeps telling do
you think he actually believes that
story happened
it did I mean it can't because there's
like it's been called into question so
many times yeah he literally said the
house burned down with his wife in it
yeah so you think that he would remember
that's not true whenever he sees his
wife is there
[Applause]
I'm not a doctor but but neither yeah
I mean forever and ever people were like
well but joke he's not going to Maui
he's not going to Maui why is he not
going to Maui I think what answered the
question is him going him out
that's why like that's
what goes and we're like oh yeah that
gotta get him out of there fast too
because it was only a matter of time
before I started babbling about how he
was actually raised by Hawaiians
yeah
yeah old sugar cane pop that sugar cane
pop yes
yeah he used to hang out with mcgarrett
I know it's bad to do this tragedy for
tragedy like you know uh it's easy to do
but in this case this is crazy right I
mean he's just he's the type of old
where if he's getting his teeth cleaned
he's just gonna touch the ass of the
dental hygienist
the way he talks Into Thin Air yeah um I
didn't mind the kitchen story I thought
it was fascinating
um
I feel for Joe Biden I mean his wife
looks like Tom Petty
um
[Applause]
rest his soul
yes
the man is daughtering it's not even
about politics there's nothing to do
with politics like I like Robert Kennedy
Jr it's the fact that he is just a
daughtering yeah blithering idiot at
this point and he's the leader of the
Free World and he literally just kind of
walks off the way your grandfather does
you're like pop pop come back come back
yes
[Applause]
Illuminati definitely got your name on
the list
all right
we must move on up next a presidential
Contender and his shirtless Splendor hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else